Buonasera a tutti Sono Antonio maconi
però stasera vorrei che foste voi a
partecipare durante questi otto minuti
che ho a disposizione quindi qui ho
portato come due mele e ci dovrebbero
essere delle ragazze ma non vedo nulla
da qua che che stanno distribuendo dei
postit su cui vorrei che voi scriveste
vostro nome e un'idea che vi è venuta in
mente oggi pomeriggio che avete in
generale un progetto qualcosa del genere
Io vi parlo appunto di fare rete e devo
dire la verità che dopo aver proposto il
tema gli organizzatori di Ted per Padova
mi sono un attimo pentito perché ho
iniziato a raccogliere un po' di
informazioni Ho cercato su Google per
trarre ispirazione e scrivendo fare rete
mi sono usciti in meno di 30 in meno di
mezzo secondo
33 milioni di risultati tutti fatto che
spiegano Come fare rete Perché fare rete
dove fare rete quando farete e allora ho
detto beh proviamo ad affinare un attimo
la ricerca e ho scelto un'espressione un
po' più
meno usata che è fare il sistema
un'altra che voi avrete immagino sentito
dire varie varie volte 24 milioni di
risultati in poco più di mezzo secondo
allora mi è venuta l'idea di cambiare
completamente approccio nel senso che
molto spesso quando si parla di fare
rete si sente dire fare rete e appunto
Sembra quasi una teoria da manuale un
dogma o il più delle volte Una specie di
è semplicemente una figura retorica fare
rete perché perché così si vince la
crisi fare rete perché è un driver per
l'innovazione altra parola spesso
montata fare rete per avere un ruolo per
avere una massa critica nella
competizione globale Allora ho pensato
di non parlare di fare rete ma di
parlare di chi fa la rete che secondo me
è la parte più interessante perché
guardando soprattutto i famosi 33
milioni di risultati di Google
vi invito a farlo tra l'altro perché è
abbastanza divertente anche se un po'
morboso le prime 10 pagine sono piene di
risultati relativi a persone che dicono
di fare rete ma poi non la fanno e
quindi per chiunque si appresti Io è da
dieci anni che più o meno
faccio rete
per chiunque si appresti a sviluppare
una propria idea e quindi cerca un
partner qualcuno che creda in questo
progetto e così via
è particolarmente utile Innanzitutto
capire da chi si deve tenere abbastanza
larga e quindi come si giocava da
bambini a Indovina chi ho pensato
innanzitutto di fare una lista di chi
sono le persone da evitare che così
intanto sfoltiamo Allora bisogna
Innanzitutto evitare le persone ma
questa è facile che non vogliono fare
rete anche se dicono è un bellissimo
progetto e poi spariscono per mesi o
anni finché ricompaiono e dicono
quell'idea bellissima perché non la
facciamo assieme queste persone
ovviamente sono del tutto inaffidabili e
quindi
evitatele e inaffidabili Perché
solitamente se un progetto desta
entusiasmo dopo un'ora che se ne è
parlato se già fatta la prima telefonata
dopo un giorno c'è già la prima bozza di
progetto dopo una settimana il primo
appuntamento per presentarlo ad un altro
partner
oltre a chi non vuole fare rete c'è
anche chi non sa fare rete sono quelle
persone che dicono facciamo rete e poi
si trincerano dietro i propri interessi
personali oppure decidono di
accumulare il maggior numero di
partner possibili e quindi ci si ritrova
Dopo
un tot di tempo con un gruppo di lavoro
enorme
di cui l'80% non sa neanche perché fa
parte di quel gruppo di lavoro il 10% è
lì perché ne trae beneficio però questi
sono parassiti non sono partner e il
restante 10% era quello iniziale
poi c'è le persone che ci sono le
persone che non possono fare rete e sono
le persone che
non sanno riconoscere il proprio ruolo
all'interno di un gruppo sono le persone
che vogliono fare il capo che non sanno
riconoscere il ruolo del capo altrui in
una nave come in questa immagine cioè il
comandante c'è il timoniere e c'è il
rematore Però tutti vogliono andare
tutti Sono sulla stessa barca e tutti
vogliono andare alla stessa stazione
allo stesso Approdo
e poi ci sono le persone che non devono
assolutamente fare rete e sono le
persone che sono alla ricerca solo ed
esclusivamente del Wow Effect ovvero di
questo effetto Wow che bello queste
persone sono quelle che vogliono fare
solo fuochi d'artificio i fuochi
d'artificio è vero Sono tanto belli però
dopo un quarto d'ora finiscono dopo 10
minuti fanno venire male al collo e
continuare a guardarli così e
soprattutto come ho letto in un articolo
qualche anno fa i fuochi d'artificio
fanno tanta luce colorano però non
riscaldano una stanza uno riscaldano un
paese o una città
Queste sono le persone già togliendo
come su Indovina chi le caselle di
queste quattro categorie rimangono poche
persone però sono le persone che almeno
di cui almeno ci si può fidare bisogna
ora capire quali sono Qual è la vera
anima gemella Perché fare rete è un po'
come una storia d'amore per chi ha avuto
esperienze ha avuto la fortuna di fare
esperienze reali di rete entrano in
causa fattori soggettivi La sintonia
l'affinità
l'entusiasmo che rendono più difficile
la scelta del partner ideale però in
questi dieci anni proprio di
osservazione e di attività sul campo mi
sono reso conto che ci sono dei tratti
le tratti comuni che rendono le persone
i partner particolarmente ideali Allora
innanzitutto è il fatto di avere la
stessa strategia
la stessa metodo la stessa la volontà di
percorrere la stessa strada
poi il fatto di avere orizzonti aperti
in un'epoca come questa che tutti stiamo
vivendo molto spesso il
le situazioni cambiano i contesti
cambiano le leggi Alcune sì altre no E
quindi bisogna essere pronti per
cambiare i propri obiettivi cambiare la
propria strategia cambiare i propri
Metodi e essere pronti a recepire delle
novità anche inaspettate
chi farete è un pioniere e questo è la
parte più importante
pioniere perché apre nuove strade oggi
pomeriggio
ma ogni volta che ascolto un una Ted
Conference su internet o altri eventi di
questo tipo molto spesso
si Ha l'impressione di essere seduti sul
palco e di essere seduti tra il pubblico
Scusate di guardare le persone sul palco
di guardare le persone che stanno
parlando dallo schermo del computer e di
dire sono dei fenomeni
io non lo riuscirò mai a fare e molto
spesso
nelle presentazioni di chi sta sul palco
si fa riferimenti a Steve Jobs non so
quante volte è stato nominato e si fa
riferimento a Einstein Fleming e ancora
una volta esempi più fenomeni che casi
reali semplicemente
ripetibili e invece secondo me
è importante parlare di quelli che a me
e alle persone che lavorano e con cui
che lavorano con me con cui ho la
fortuna di lavorare
e Preferisco molto di più parlare di
innovatori cioè di persone che tutti i
giorni fanno innovazione E che di fatto
sono dei veri e propri visionari non nel
senso italiano del termine però di
persone che utopiste che non
inconcludenti che non raggiungono un
obiettivo ma visionario un po' nel senso
inglese del termine visionary persone
che hanno una visione che come questa
persona nell'immagine apre una nuova
strada
Qual è il nostro problema adesso nella
situazione in cui ci troviamo nel 2014
il problema fondamentale è il fatto che
noi non abbiamo bisogno di fenomeni ma
abbiamo bisogno di creare una dinamica
abbiamo bisogno che tutte queste persone
che ogni giorno stanno e producono i
famosi fabbricatori di idee
sappiano che ci sono altri fabbricatori
di idee abbiamo bisogno di smetterla di
reggere e di i titoli di giornali in cui
si scrive è necessario fare rete ma
abbiamo bisogno di leggere articoli di
persone che la rete l'hanno fatta
davvero
sono casi molto spesso normali le
stampanti 3D di cui ha parlato Stefano
Micelli prima
dietro la porta praticamente a pochi
chilometri da qui
che potranno cambiare la nostra vita
Questo è vero ma che sono fatte da
persone assolutamente comuni non da
fenomeni e qui Vi spiego il perché delle
mele
e dei post-it soprattutto quando ero
piccolo piccolo adolescente a 15 anni ho
letto un libro
e lì mi ha colpito una citazione che
molto spesso viene
utilizzata tantissime volte da chi parla
di fare rete di innovazione e così via E
questa è una citazione di un premio
Nobel per la letteratura se ho anche
dice se io ho una mela e tu hai una mela
e ci scambiamo la mela alla fine abbiamo
una mela ciascuna Ma se io ho un'idea e
io scambio un'idea con te alla fine
andiamo a casa ciascuno con due idee e
allora ritorno all'inizio vi chiederei
di essere protagonisti se avete scritto
qualcosa su questo post-it soprattutto
Vi è arrivato il post it però non riesco
veramente a vedere
quando uscite fra due presentazioni di
sopra consegnatelo alle ragazze che lo
attaccheranno su un pannello Andate a
vedere e a leggere le altre idee delle
altre persone Ho parlato stamattina con
gli organizzatori della Ted e poi
posteranno tutte queste idee sul sito
internet e magari se siete fortunati
come io sono stato fortunato 3 anni fa
troverete delle persone con cui
realizzare queste idee ancora non
fenomeni ma persone con cui dare il
nuovo lancio a questo paese Grazie